&gt;&gt; When we answer these sorts of questions and make these types of calculations,
we're actually using algebra. We're creating and using linear equations. But in
algebra, we don't stop at the question, how much would 20 miles cost. We ask how
much would x miles cost. I want to know the cost of my truck rental for any of
the number of miles I drive it. So here's the big question. What expression can
we write here that represents the cost of our truck rental in terms of the
number of miles we drove x? Try thinking about the pattern in this table, and
take some time. Don't worry if you don't know how to do this just yet. I want to
get you thinking, and I want to try and give you a shot at it. Finally, when you
enter your answer, don't use the dollar sign. Just write the expression.